foreign
I knew you couldn't finish
[Laughter]
I would give you many children of pure
Valerian blood hey how are you that was
good why don't you have a seat right
over there man would sooner put the
round to the torch
and see a woman Ascend the iron throne
beginning tonight King's Landing will
learn to fear the color gold
I'm not dead yeah he says he's not dead
yes he is
[Music]
n't that look wonderful if you really
pay me enough we'll massage you feeding
any of these sauces also
City makers Kings
dragon's dead choke me devil daddy choke
me
under the
dragon's eyes
again
say it our children
a buster
the last of the Valyrian pyromancers hid
his song it must deal
[Music]
we have 30 nights 100 crossbow men and
300 men at Arms I gotta pump those
numbers up those are rookie numbers in
this racket now fighting now farting now
fighting
no
added to the chair
wow now this is a risky business
congratulations
what a blessing this is for you but what
she meant to say was bye [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's our burn book so we cut out girls
pictures from the yearbook and then we
wrote comments
I would like to see the baby
my boy's on me turn around
hold up wait a minute
yeah my breath I
mean
[Music]
enough
[Music]
hello darkness my old friend
[Music]
add it to the chair
[Music]
behold the pink dress oh my dude you're
dude you just got pranked bet you didn't
see that one coming huh
it's me
it's me
[Music]
bye
he's already dead
this is why men wage war
because a woman would never be ready for
the battle in time
[Laughter]
it isn't so bad mostly he just ignores
you
except sometimes when he's drunk what
the [ __ ]
foreign